welcome this via play motor home again
we had a really wild game earlier so I
kept playing my age three pet line again
okay I want some peace and quiet let's
just go for them the end game here and
easy to play variation that should at
least give me a quiet life okay yeah he
didn't play Bishop e7 first interesting
he takes Bishop Jake's a form this pin
is having some annoyance value not much
okay well this line is not very young
very young ambitious anyway for white
but it at least give some gives the
whole thing it leads to us simple to
play positions what I'm getting at okay
here i can take not sure trying to try
to do something with with the connected
pathway with the best porn on d5
interesting okay
probably want the King to help ruge FC
one he's got two against one though
maybe night a 62 beforehand is something
that is just okay yeah maybe night
before now it's not really helping I
mean I can go we should be one when
Bishop g2 yeah this one on the other
hand I just got bit up f8 all the time
yeah I see okay I should probably try to
to prepare an exchange of this in mind
if I do it now only three mmm this got
Bishop b5 coming
hmm yeah that wasn't a good idea
probably the whole thing this allowing
him and those two pawns look sir it
looks very yeah I Wow takes be three
very uncomfortable wow how how bad did I
play this great okay okay can I do
something against this before pawn Wow
yeah I got played this amazingly well
amazingly amazingly well yeah amazingly
terrible maybe I can get in Bishop d2
and something against the pawn Wow
so push up t to one snide a six yeah
okay I need to do this anyway huh I
don't have that the whole thing is this
is really really terrible I mean it
probably is terrible anyway but okay if
I take be for now night b3m remarkable
oh I really don't see a movie
yeah taking night p3s it's really
horrible maybe this to take it okay
maybe night a six-figure even has to go
night asics I might be able maybe it can
play Bishop d3 somehow hanging on for a
moment
Wow
I was a really bad opening play
so what happens now if I take before he
plays what Knight takes Knight takes you
for yeah okay come I don't know this is
a this is really really bad anyway takes
takes take here taking what the bishop
gives up the porn essentially maybe I
can hang on with 93 or something a 93 I
can even consider to take on t2 with
this check coming but I can take before
I looks into I can take the form takes
takes hmm maybe if I can put the Bishop
to c4 then okay if I take a 3 now he has
the check time morning it's got the
check yeah but I can I can interpose
with 96 check
check just about to hang on okay oh no I
cannot go them okay so so we will get
this and at least ya get the King echtor
wow what the wrong game okay but maybe
my beep on gives me some counterplay
always stay positive keep that for the
moment
todo an IBM then push be formed King to
d5 is helpful certainly and I'll push
this thing check
I'm going to offer him a drawing offered
check okay check check check cannot do
more than that sorry guy okay now I mean
I don't like to win on time in those
kind of situations where you totally
outplayed me but okay I don't resign now
I mean I feel the droids okay if he if
he is in this kind of situation yeah
well this was terrible right how did I
get into this this really really awful
position let's look at this this is
definitely normal and I think a four is
also Muslim and he went here hmm ya know
how did that happen maybe d6 I don't
know I mean maybe this is just bad it's
possible I was sort of tempted because
of the protected passer on the D file
but okay this is just nothing that
happened that helps me in a way Jim and
it got ugly really really quickly maybe
we should be three here first ma'am
maybe this is one it probably I mean
this is not promising for wide in any
case that's clear but mmm it probably
was piling up a couple of couple of bad
moves piling up here here this is
exceptionally ugly stuff
what is the cult giving should've ate
him s all preparing this gym it's just
just really really bad and what he did
is totally sufficient damn it or it all
wins yeah just to stone can't spend and
spend ages yeah okay I feel how awful I
draw this is ok thing I mean he's losing
on time I'm losing position wise ok
thanks for watching